yay welcome back to new rockstars news
everyone we are talking about Aquaman
and spider-man into the spider-verse
we're also gonna be talking about the
new men and black trailer the new reboot
that just came out in a potential Nova
movie we're hearing stuff about I'm Erik
Bosse join him here at the table or Sam
bachelor and Maude Garrett let's talk
about the top story it just came out
today we actually have two movies to
discuss we're gonna start with Aquaman
is directed by James 1 know mostly for
horror movies like saw and the conjuring
movies he's also executive producing
Swamp Thing show that's coming out what
you also did Fast & Furious in charge of
a lot of big franchises so this is the
first superhero 1 unless you consider
Dom Toretto a superhero he can't be
killed family is important his
superpowers family now this movie stars
Jason Momoa and Amber Heard and
currently on Rotten Tomatoes has 68
percent according to critics so a bit of
a mixed bag with opinions here this is
something I've amber heard a lot of
things about is maybe great what did you
think buddy
hold on real quick well he is a pretty
into it I've heard so many things about
this movie I haven't actually managed to
see yet only because I do a lot of
junket that I'm watching all the crap
around the world it's tough but um I'm
been hearing that it's the worst movie
some in this room has probably ever seen
and wanted to walk out I've heard other
people say that it was actually really
really great they loved the direction of
this and it could do good things for DC
and I'm hearing a mixed bag of things so
I kind of want to get you guys
convincing me whether I should see this
movie I'll give it a me and you've both
seen it and you've got mixed opinions as
well definitely see it it definitely see
it and you can do a red block a red box
rental with this no you gotta see it on
the big screen the visuals are so
amazing in fact they're one of them
there's a couple amazing things that
make this movie worth seeing individuals
are at the top most importantly just
because it's in my peripheral vision
areas nipples hard being ty
well when he's in the water I mean these
doesn't have a shirt on if you can't
tell if he's got shirt on you know I
mean usually yeah those things are
fighting okay they're sharp but when
you're talking about positives of the
movie I'd honestly I'm lukewarm on it
like I think I'm bummed that that
percentage dropped one percentage point
because before it was really funny but
anyways I know I I left this movie
pretty much in the middle of the road
like I don't think there are some
moments where I actually genuinely like
disliked it but overall it's a fun romp
and I've heard some comparisons too it's
not a comic book adaptation it's an
adaptation of a Saturday morning cartoon
so like like in Super Friends how
Aquaman is riding that giant pink
seahorse you're like he's already lame
and this is his first like TV show in
this they make him a giant sea dragon
and he looks awesome this movie is
badass like through and through but like
from the visuals to how they're even
able to bring this world to life like
James Wan needs to be praised and the
fact that he makes an underwater world
where people aren't walking around
they're floating constantly that no one
ever is just a normal person in the
scene that's beautiful yeah it can be it
does feel a little exhausting at times
but here's the thing he believed James 1
did the best possible job you could
adapting the bonkers character that his
Aquaman to the big screen and he
embraces that this world are very well
defined he fixed a lot of the things
that I believe were mistakes in Justice
League one of them being characters can
only talk to each other in air bubbles
and this one he just says no people can
talk to each other underwater sounded
weirdly muted and we're just gonna go
with that yeah it feels like a really
well designed world it there's parts of
it where I'm like hi this is how I felt
like when I was watching Finding Nemo
the cameras swooping in this underwater
Kingdom you do have to let go of certain
cynicism that I think we all naturally
have seen a lot of superhero movies
where they do it really well I think
yeah there's some things where it's just
a little silly but I think if you can
just like push through that and just
like enjoy the ride octave was playing
drums just off to us playing drums
tattooed octopus plays drums before a
battle and it's awesome I haven't seen
that since a little moment it's amazing
yeah it's like actually
plays the flute the cup plays the heart
he was behind something I wish we had a
full man I'll tell you it would have
been more impressive yeah I think James
once said that this guy's name is so
toto uh no no I'm busy from Africa chapo
turbo he is a to remember that song
because it's featured and there's a
cover of it by now show up in every
movie no I'm not just saying like I'm
hate watching this the way that we watch
a b-movie I genuinely enjoyed certain
elements of it because I think you could
there's another version of this movie
where they call out everything where
they're like yeah I know and they're
kind of ashamed of the history and
there's no there's no self-consciousness
maybe some fans wanted at some point
Jason Momoa to look a camera and be like
seriously I'm gonna ride a seahorse or
something like that or exactly what Ben
Affleck did and that Justice League
trailer of like so I hear you talk to
fish this movie I think one of the best
things about without spoiling it they
think the power of communicating with
fish and turn it from something really
dumb in the city or key into the one
thing that redeems the character in the
end of the movie and it works
it totally pays off the fact that he can
communicate with sea creatures is the
thing that saves him yeah makes them the
hero
it's and it works and I think that's a
humor to pull off know it there's a when
it comes to visuals and action there's a
hand-to-hand fight between arms brother
and Jason Momoa Arthur curry and they go
they go at it underwater and it's
beautiful I've never seen like it's one
of the most impressive actions yeah
scenes I've seen all year because they
make it look believable they actually do
they do the effort to like make it work
but where this movie like start stuff
like lose me is that the script and the
moments where I'm supposed to actually I
can learn more about the characters and
who they are I'm like totally written
its when it when you have like personal
moments the other moments like the story
beats and everything are pretty epic the
movie is epic the movie is fully
embraces every weird aspect of Aquaman
and makes you understand it but doesn't
like hold your hand through it it's just
like let's just see this weird universe
it's not even like you know how
the MCU has like let's say teamironman
you have jon favreau pepper potts and
brody sometimes if he's there but with
this it's like no you're seeing like
seven kingdoms like your senior and
you're exploring all of them to the
fullest okay great and they all feel
distinct and different that's cool and I
will say that Sam is on to something
when it comes to character development
this movie does leave some to be desired
in that print if you just compare it I
don't want to compare it just to like
marble but like there's lots of stories
it's a very Arthurian legend of the
outcast character who has to like
reclaim his throne right we saw in the
Lion King were seen in Game of Thrones
with Jon Snow we kind of saw Star Wars
which is a direct reference they don't
shy away from that movie it's a little
on the knight slew my mind like three
weeks ago where I was like only King
Arthur yeah and he's like why don't we
name him after King Arthur is gonna be
Arthurian story great they they do it a
little bit better than other stories
because I don't know if we learn
anything about what makes Arthur curry
distinct from those other types of art
their stories where we see why he
doesn't want it he's a pretty
one-dimensional surfer bro yeah it was
straight at a point break yeah I don't
learn anything really more about him
Sean Penn struggle yeah I mean Black
Panther is another story like this where
we learn quite a bit about T'Challa and
like he's shame about what the mistakes
that his father made and how he felt
like a bit of a betrayal to his family
yeah a bit a bit and I think this
doesn't really do anything to improve on
that so you're gonna miss out on that
but I think in terms of the story and
the pacing of the story it's a pretty
fun adventure and it almost has the
Raiders of the Lost Ark kind of feel
we're all going from the next step of
like trying to find this lost relic and
I was excited by its Tron mixed with
Point Break mixed with national treasure
mixed with Indiana Jones there is a
specific scene that is from national
treasure it's just done with it bottle
and it's just it's a different bottle it
used even like using blood to like use
to like read something there's a lot of
stuff that's like I don't already oh
yeah it's great I've got two questions
how my girls nicole kidman crazy
wonderful gives my favorite performer in
the movie she gets the first action
scene of the movie and it was it's a
there's no cut in it as far as you can
tell and it's just it blew my mind
I was like okay I could be on board with
this then people start talking later and
I start to zone out but she gets awesome
moments throughout the movie how's Julie
Andrews yes ridiculous this is that the
probably the peak moment where I'm like
what is going very pop ins and Maria
from sound of music voice seen this
giant Lovecraftian scene demon wonderful
see she's not doing like no she's uh
she's channeling a very Shakespearean
he's a tight power she's yeah yeah yeah
force of nature voice acting is
wonderful and it's it I'd say just to
kind of sum up like I think this movie
shines light on everything great about
James Wallace directing and everything
that doesn't work all the time it's like
he knows action he knows how to capture
amazing moments in you know CGI like the
CGI needs to be praised this movie
because it's amazing it's wonderful and
then when it comes to script stuff it's
like the like like Amber Heard and
Arthur I'm like I'm waiting for you guys
to have chemistry you're just telling us
that there is and I don't feel it so yes
I agree there there Amir is awesome by
the way as a character mayor it's great
Amber Heard is is very good her
performance your I did not feel the
chemistry I felt like in the second half
of the movie they forced a rom-com
subplot that did not work I couldn't
maybe brother and sister mmm well
they're married in the comics it's one
of the big like marriages and coming in
yeah I know that you don't have to do
that but hey flash made a couple half
siblings or not half siblings adopted
siblings that was weird and we all have
to live with that it's super weird so
and maybe that's not so much diversity
they did it's representation matters now
here's a question I actually do love the
fact that he's at first like Polynesian
to be here right and there's a lot of
like references to his Polynesian answer
la the necklace is a it's a memory toki
jade necklace and his tattoos are all
polynesian tattoos so any day yeah it's
Murrah morrison is a yeah you quickly
agreed to Orson Ponies I don't I get
that
you might be a New Zealander we do know
everything as modi fact that he did the
haka on the carpet you know all that
kind of there was a little bit of it in
the movie during a fight like a when he
was like in the middle of battle and
like he like it's a moment where he like
takes down somebody I was like oh yeah
it's so strong and I love the history of
that and I love that it's seeing in like
a mainstream capacity yeah I'm not
digging on diversity at all I just think
that flash it was weird I get I agree it
was weird but I think it's it's just I
wish that the script had one more pass
in this movie could be a even more
special but I think that Ron tomato's
great is actually pretty pretty on the
money I'd maybe make a little bit higher
but that's pretty that's pretty on the
money yeah I think this movie will do
pretty good overseas I mean it's got all
the kind of right elements that I think
international audiences will go for
we'll see how much money it makes and
that'll depend a lot on whether this is
kind of the norm for DC going forward
with the Warner Brothers films or this
is just kind of an outlier it was in our
pipeline we're gonna change our
direction after this we have Shazam in
the pipeline it's wrong and then yeah
but I don't know this is good enough to
be like yes this is what I want to see
for every DC Wonder Woman did initially
when that first came out it's like oh
here we go you're on the map I will say
this is the biggest like superhero movie
they've ever made like Avengers infinity
war it's big but scale wise this is way
bigger than Justice League he goes to
Seven Kingdoms and they're not like oh
it's like the size of an eye is it's
like no this is a this is a Kingdom
Kingdom the world building of this movie
is what is the one reason why I watch it
in the cinema
either it's long and that the script
sometimes long personal scenes I'm like
they're they're grading but like that it
is I'm I'm just saying that I get I got
tired but I think the visual the visuals
are impressive but maybe wait for Redbox
I say see it on the big screen I think
those you'll be grateful when you see
their shots entering the world we're
seeing the world billions the best part
of it it's kind of like when that moment
when you watch then enter Wakanda or
certain of the shots when they interview
I mean it was a bad movie but the
underwater going into Naboo for Phantom
Menace was still
delightful Italy you like that you're
gonna love Aquaman if you could get by
comment below if you've seen the movie
let me know whether I should see it in
the cinema or if I should have a hard
pass on that one yeah and we want to
hear your thoughts on this movie how
does it rank among the other DC
cinematic adaptations 68% fair is that
fair yeah let us know but let's move on
to our trivia question now folks we have
a huge announcement as you've seen if
you watch the show every week we have a
gif of shame challenge that we do for
the people who lose a question and the
boxes we've had it was shame in itself a
batteries it was great I miss it it
served its function but it wasn't very
good well we asked some of you you'd be
interested in helping us make a new one
and one of you on Twitter
Travis Travis is one of the coolest guys
ever he freaking made us a gif of shame
box and guys it looks awesome the way
that is it's really cool he made this
out of wood and laser printing and he
sent it to us in pieces that we can
assemble individually all of our gif of
shame moments that we have had this year
that have been etched in and as you can
see Eric's is when we were doing our
Halloween special and he's in his shock
hotdog suit I wanted that for today's
episode in honor of into the
spider-verse but we also made this gif
of shame shame shame this side you could
see he wrote shame shame shame
it's Marvel and of course cars it means
you're watching the moneymaker it's a
moneymaker it's a quarter of a million
so thank you Travis we can't wait to use
this every week and give you a shout out
this is such a kind gesture and we're so
excited to reach into something that
to have some vitals on it or have an
animal living in it so let's get your
question this week and here we go so the
question is named another project in
which Jason Momoa played an excellent
swimmer okay all of our answers are here
in the bin and at the end of the episode
we'll reveal the answer to the trivia
question I'm sorry I'm just want to
point out my real smugface
mod feels good about it we'll pull our
gift shame whoever loses from our new
amazing great I feel like I'm on like a
late night show you know with like the
give the Walker Texas Ranger lever like
these cool little hidden things that
like feels legit like we have arrived
now we got a great cool stuff I mean the
sets I think we picked it a little Groot
by the way how you feeling Groot
good agree I am Groot means we other
stuff came out that we want to talk
about sure did I don't know if you've
heard of this little movie that's making
big waves
Sonique spider-man into this
spider-verse came out last week it's
written by phil lord chris miller was
producer on that one and came out last
weekend
now you guys watched into the
spider-verse I watched welcome to Marwin
tomato tomato so I really do want to
hear a lot about into the spider both
because this is like honestly like movie
of the year for a lot of people so just
before we get into that I'm gonna tell
you why you shouldn't see that's what
they want to know why
it's so unfortunate at the moment when
it's junket season for me and where a
lot of movies come out and the movies
that I watch because I have to because
they interview the cast for and lately
there have been some doozies and welcome
to Marwan is a story that it's it's
supposed to be an inspirational story
based on a documentary which is about a
quite a sad story about a man who had
the living beaten out of him because he
happened to casually mention in a bar
that he liked wearing women's shoes and
the way that he got through his coma and
he's completely like completely had his
memory wiped
he turned to his art and he would create
little towns and dolls and take photos
of it but this movie manages like the
one thing that it's trying to do is make
women a powerful force and to celebrate
women but what it ends up doing is
removed so much power from women and
make so many things uncomfortable and
awkward and borderline creepy and makes
you as the audience not sure whether you
want to you can no longer sort of
support and be on this guy's side
because he crosses so many boundaries
and it's done in just such a distorted
way but the visuals are great he does
this really cool thing I mean he's
trying to push visual boundaries like
with Polar Express you know that was
supposed to be revolutionary we're sort
of like mocap for the face this time he
basically does create dolls of all of
these actors and it looks freakishly
real so that part's cool but when once
you actually consider the story halfway
through the movie I was like oh I
actually don't feel good
like I don't feel good about anything
that's happening here we're kind of
turning on it it sounds like that's a
big miss for me I know that I didn't get
it gave it a two point five out of ten
that's what I'm gonna just start off
with let's talk about one of the better
movies that came out ya know what was it
about spider-man into the spider verse
that really knocked your socks off I
mean everything across the board like I
I've been lucky enough a little
humblebrag
i've been able to see this movie wait
four times why I gotta yeah I know I'm
going to see it a fifth time next week
and very excited about it I love it it's
it's an amazing movie that has heart has
an amazing script he
there the voice cache is incredible and
but above all like honestly it's didn't
even though they're all equal in my
brain because they they just nailed it
is the animation style like I yeah they
animated this entire movie in CGI and
then they created a software to go back
frame by frame and do hand-drawn
touch-ups and so that like and that's
never been done before right the entire
movie is hand-drawn and a blend of CG
and I get why somebody's trying to
patent that technology it's like that's
that's incredible it took a week to do
one second of film that's how that's how
much care and effort went into this
movie and the way like in like seems
like this must have been the hardest
because Nic Cage is spider-man you are
spider-ham and penny and your main three
casts are all rendered out differently
yeah they're all burn animations
information stuff it would be murdering
your normal computer like I don't even
know how they even pulled that off it's
so impressed a true like miracle of
filmmaking in my opinion it's alright I
talked a bit about this in the breakdown
that we did of it the animator said they
had to do what's called animate and twos
where in addition to do handmade
hand-drawn touch-ups normally in film
you do 24 frames per second that's what
gives it that smooths kind of lifelike
action here they went back to old-school
animation which is 12 frames per second
so they held each frame twice so it
gives a kind of this chunky almost like
comic-book turn page motion strobe
almost effect which some people are kind
of like it throws them off for a bit but
this is the first time I feel like
they've really brought a comic book to
light made it feel like a living
painting so it's just a visual spectacle
but it's not just like you know when
Angley did like the split screens in the
original Hulk movie or in Scanner Darkly
where they kind of did some weird
animation style here it really feels
like you're turning a page and they use
Miles Morales artistic style of graffiti
a spray painting of it's doodles to
animate all the splash pages so it feels
like you're not just reading a comic
book you're reading a comic book that
Miles Morales could have conceived
conceivably drawn so you really get a
sense of the character more than a lot
of other superhero movies do they
introduce you to who Miles Morales is
why fans love them in the comics the
animated series and make us fall in love
with him while introducing this whole
idea of the spider-verse which is a
really
complicated thing to do in a movie and
also I pull it off I went with a friend
I went with you know Darrin I brought
him to one of the screenings I went to
and he was like it do you know like when
like a sci-fi concept comes up and
sometimes you're like I don't get it but
like you just don't want to ask
questions because sometimes nerdy
culture is a little bit more harsh when
it comes to asking questions yeah and he
was like oh I finally get it
like I get the multiverse I understand I
think I kind of got it like not time
travel but something else in like these
other people he's like I just you know
he's like I kind of ignored it but this
movie did a good job but also the best
part about this for me is that it has
one of the most beautiful lessons in the
movie like it it the point of it is is
that anyone can be spider-man that's the
point you can be that you even say that
in the movie he's narrating me miles is
narrating it he's saying you can be but
it's not about being spider-man being a
superhero whatever it's like it means
that you have the opportunities in life
when you're faced with challenges you
can be a good person you can rise above
it and that's and you that is realized
and one of the best scenes in cinema you
know when Wonder Woman walks out of the
trench and everyone got chills and they
were crying that's what this scene is
this movie has that and it's beautiful
because miles is a great character and
it's and they bring up they just bring
to life everything that you love about
spider-man and everything that every
other non comic book reader is missing
by not reading those stories Sam you are
glowing it's the best movie of the year
no there's some wonderful movies this
year but I honestly think this movie
because like like Scanner Darkly and
other animation styles like they try to
like show adults like no animation
school look at it it's pressive it's
like no you're going you're on too edgy
there's other examples I'm not thinking
of right now and then everyone else
thinks cartoons this movie is a movie
it's a comedy it's a drama it's it's a
sci-fi adventure and it shows people
that you can really use animation to
tell any story you want and it deserves
respect yes absolutely I really gush
about this for a long time I think this
movie's perfect also 3d makes this movie
actually wonderful like I would never
advocate for 3d X ever animation is a
good 3 he's a good medium for animation
I've got a couple of questions obviously
there's been a lot of spider-man hit and
misses like I feel like this is the the
cash cow that keeps getting milked you
know and we thought that that was dry
maybe not because of Tom Holland but
like well getting to that stage do you
think that this was successfully
resurrected the spider-man franchise the
year of spider-man
100% wouldn't say resurrected but I feel
like it has taken it into a new
potentially beneficial direction that
they should be doing more
experimentation with and the way that
comic books started to have to branch
out and try new visual styles and new
different kinds of stories doing the
same Peter Parker story over and over
again it felt like third time's a charm
with Tom Hollands like okay finally we
got it we're good that those movies can
be totally fine I love that they're
doing this new animation style to show
there's a whole new different side of
this world that's out there and I hope
that they do this with more superhero
characters and this movie's deeper than
you think because like with Peters
character in this Jake Johnson by the
way has my favorite Jackson movie
there's a there's a joke that they're
like heat they always make a joke that
he's like a little bit thicker than like
other spider-man because he's older but
also he's tired and he's tired and also
we're maybe tired of seeing him on
screen like a little bit I love my
spider-man but come on and that's a joke
that you see and he gets revitalized by
being around these people and seeing
like what the point of being spider-man
is this is kind of like our first
version on the big screen of Miles
Morales how was that how did they do it
do they do it justice they improved
actually healed it yeah I mean schmick
Moore's voice acting is fantastic and he
could tell it they animated certain
facial expressions that feel very like
lifelike and the way Pixar does a really
good job of characterizing just with
like very like you know little human
emotional tics they they nailed that
with him and they they brought in the
whole culture of the character he is
he's a son of Porto Rican and the black
parents and that is in every frame of
this movie and when it comes to the
music when it comes around fine it's
it's so a ground level of the character
it doesn't feel like it's just tokenism
and there's an interview with Phil Lord
where they're like why didn't you
subtitle when Spanish is spoken in the
movie it's like because it's not about
you understanding it's about his culture
it's like that's who he is it doesn't
matter what he's saying you can
understand that this is what he means to
is like to his neighborhood and to his
family and you don't need to know that
part it's just showing that he is more
than what you're seeing there's more
truth also they created the art the
artists part that that in the comics he
does not have that and I think that's an
amazing thing that's in this movie yeah
and yeah it feels like very Brooklyn
movie too because you know
with with spider-man traditionally as a
queen space superhero but the yeah
there's this is a very Brooklyn movie
and it feels the setting is very much a
part of this movie in ways that you
don't normally see even in in spider-man
homecoming it took place in Queens but I
don't really feel like but this you know
we're not gonna there are some gripes we
can make about it but we really just
want you to go see it and spider-gwen I
was she because this is again the first
kind of iteration that we've seen of her
on the big screen and brought to life
there's some criticism that like in the
comics she wears like these like
turquoise like teal teal sneakers like
these Nikes and they're they're great
and I always wanted a pair and this they
give her ballet shoes and people like oh
you're like you know you're making
because she's the girl you're making in
the girl it's like no actually they give
her the she is still the same person and
she has all like the baddest
characteristics but now she is able to
use dance as the reason why she is so
limber and quick it like knowing how to
be Spirent basically immediately and she
knows how to like use your body while
everybody else is clumsy she like
already has an idea of handle on how to
do that and I think that's so I think
that's so cool and there's a moment
where all the spiderman are trying to
like get miles to be spider-man they're
like trying to get him to be better and
she brings up like can you move through
the air like with the grace of a trained
dancer and it's like actually you need
to be able to do that cuz measurements
so she's the gymnast basically she's
that gymnast side of him and you know
they are talking about sequels and
spin-offs and there's gonna be like gwen
stacy appearing in more movies either
live-action or animated but this is a
great movie to introduce who she is to
people who might not initially go see a
movie about spider gwyn or not even know
what that is now people know and now
people really excited to see more I do
like seeing the spider green suit as
well apparently though this one's been
getting 97% are rotten tomatoes it's
already talking about sequels and
spin-offs as well we've got a chat about
the Spider Woman movie that's happening
you're a big fan of that one because
there's a lots of spider women as well
and there's just like there's lots of
spider-man's men by demand pigs of
animals
I say Spider Man's written out one time
I'm like that can't be right that that
can't be right
how is it going I'm said what do girls
ninety-seven percent on Rotten Tomatoes
I'd it's too low it's good its I mean
there's a reason why critics are loving
it and like look at the audience score
to as like an A+ audience core that's
probably even even better indicator know
what you're in fourth but something just
dropped out yesterday right well yes
there's a new men and black trailer and
it dropped this week which is exciting
it's starring Tessa Thompson and Chris
Hemsworth so a little for Ragnarok
reunion makes us all happy we notice a
couple fun things in the trailer so we
thought we'd do a little mini breakdown
for you guys so buckle up click click
and do another one click click it's a
butterfly when you go on roller coasters
because this one's give you a wild ride
the painting on the right if you notice
right here is a Will Smith and Tommy Lee
Jones fighting Vincent d'Onofrio's Roach
guy from men and black one that's a fan
favorite looks like the one on the right
could be of Liam Neeson and Chris
Hemsworth too which is fun I have been
jerking about playing Vincent D'Onofrio
for years now and I've like I go on
Amazon I've got all the pieces I just
have to do it because you know I would
commit yeah usually yeah because he puts
his hand up when he's about to like kill
those guys in the diner
he's praying everything yeah you should
do a breakdown of this movie when it
comes out as that character yes and in
character breakdown yeah but on next we
see Emma Thompson in the trailer which
is exciting but she isn't playing a new
character by the way you may not have
seen it but she was already introduced
in men in black 3 as agent OH which is
pretty cool
in your speech where she says she gives
the speech where she says she we are a
rumor is actually quoting chief Zedd
who's played by Rip Torn
and men black one right after he has
Will Smith's Agent J burn off his
fingerprints he tells him you are a
rumor when my favorite scenes also as a
kid I was like got me scared you grab a
cup of coffee after that cuz I was like
we don't wanna burn my super cool and
also these right here look like an
update to the noisy cricket model guns
which fan favorite yeah look a little
bit of it
they're more like a magnum how do I know
that I don't have never held a gun Oh
Goldeneye yeah and also Madame black has
always had a classic understated kinda
retro SIA
serious motif yeah yes movies their cars
used to be simple older black sedans
like Agent J thought they were boring
until he saw that what they could do
which was always an exciting moment for
me in the theaters this tradition is
maintained with the car you see here
though they also drive eight 2018-2019
Lexus and they'd punching on that so
hard I get that K ish and just like in
the first movie there's a classic
Hamilton Ventura watch who is beautiful
classy because it was regarded as one of
the first ever electric watch that one
and then there's this small Thor
reference right here he throws the
hammer and the bad guy catches it just
like hella does in thor ragnarok thank
you guys that they are not wearing ties
and that it's like open and at the cuffs
have kind of like the way Harry Potter
robes rooms sleep okay with that I think
this movie to me I'm I'm interested to
see it hopefully they'll recapture that
kind of subversive humor that was in the
first movie because that's what makes
men in black great is they're kind of
like they're joking the fact like there
they put Will Smith who was just coming
out of doing frickin Independence Day
and they emasculate him with this little
tiny gun and it's awesome it's not about
the guns in the cars it's about like
this kind of old-school this it's cool
super cop who has to join this like you
know he's gotta start at the entry level
ground floor of this secret organization
that's really quirky and weird and fun
and this seems too much like cool right
like like it's like a little kid
watching men in black 3 or the animated
show just for like the explosions and
effects
I missed the quirkiness I missed the
quirkiness in the first one but I know
you're a huge fan of these what I
noticed my first of all I'm team Tessa I
think she's great I love the fact that
it's a male-female duo and the fact that
these guys had previous chemistry I
think will really resonate on screen
this actually felt a lot like Kingsman
to me
felt like Kingsman with aliens that was
very men in black story too of like
initiate exactly it's a whole new world
announced to you and it's like the
gadgets which was very James Bond as but
it's like yeah they're kind of like I
think if Kingsman is more of like a
younger James Bond or like you know
because you got like the Chad guy who's
turning into the the British you know
the the elite agent and in this stage
yet you've got people that are a little
bit clueless that are figuring out that
aliens do exist and there's a whole
organization out there I really I'm I'm
really all about these concepts I I'm
excited yeah hundred percent and also I
like the idea international why wouldn't
we want to see what aliens were doing in
other places around the world I know New
York's fun that's why every superhero
thing takes place in that city but like
also show what's Australia actually an
alien it's an exit so it comes out a
shell of a giant toy it's gonna happen I
yeah I think the casting is probably the
biggest selling point for me and I think
they should do that rather than take a
star out of whatever they were great in
and put them in a new franchise take
duo's and trios and just put them in I
kind of like keeping chemistry alive
because that's really what it's all
about
didn't have it and it wrecked the movie
a little bit mmm
yep okay well now for a fun Avengers in
game theory in January of this year
lethal carrot on Twitter asked guardians
of the galaxy writer director James Gunn
about that tool that Rocket used in
guardians to remembers the one that he
used to repair the ship and then James
Gunn reply it's in the tool keeps the
entire ship in its memory and can
recreate it just for the damaged parts
similar to an incredibly sophisticated
3d printer it's just kind of like this
is what it was and we're just gonna
spray it back on it's gonna go back
there so Naughty Dog's on reddit
wondered what if Tony finds one of these
tools laying around like could he use it
to repair the ship the Benatar that he's
on and I mean he uses on the Bennett are
in the it's a guardianship it could be
the same we saw the Bennett or and
guardians to right that was what it was
or was it the Milan and the Milano
crashed in the first and then the
Benatar was the second one that john c
reilly made
yes yeah it's and that's the one that
they have in Avengers infinity words so
when the Tonys on so do you guys think
this is possible is that a way that Tony
could could science his way out of this
rescue himself find this little spray
gun and repair the ship on his own
vision what caught this guy build I
don't know if he needs like any kind of
thing he could probably build one of
those toys what was it that uh war
monger said he built this in a cave
right that's the question it's a
drifting in space and he doesn't had a
few Lisa feels about to run out but its
navigation broken that that's my kind of
question because like you would think
he'd be able to I mean we don't know if
the benatar can find its way to earth
yeah it's it's you know well he did have
yeah so why wouldn't he be able to at
least set himself toward the vector of
earthbound you know and am I thinking is
some kind of navigation is damaged when
when the plane landed or maybe you know
they de mistura moon at Titan maybe yeah
maybe it got damaged a little bit and
that's why he would need to repair it it
can't just be supplied maybe it's an
awfully convenient piece of machinery
though might be fine but maybe what
they're lacking is hope Tony and in
nebula would have found it by now right
they probably ransacked that ship
looking for it she was I would love to
see that I used to get no I I thought
that was such a cool little like he's
just pressure pressure rushing the ship
back together I thought that was such a
fun like Walkingstick
I think it'll depend on the tone of this
movie right like it could go in the
direction of being more like guardians
thor ragnarok style or it could be a bit
more grounded like you know Winter
Soldier very Civil War kind of grounded
I think it's it senses the Russos is
probably gonna be a bit more but let us
know what you guys think in the comments
below I think it's a super interesting
theory but some other news
I'm out sure did this week the live
action
Aladdin movie released some first look
pics including a very non blue genie on
Instagram though Will Smith said he
would be CGI and blue for most of the
movie so apparently this is just like at
the start but it's a clear image for me
maybe there was huge amounts of backlash
and that's why they are backpedaling
real bad and they probably have to
change most of the movie because there
wasn't to make him cry
disappointment who knows it could he it
could just be like all right dude now
that you know I'm maybe I'm freaking out
because I got no legs and I'm a weird
and maybe is this like okay does this
help and he looks like that who knows do
you guys think at 20 years there's gonna
be like that Mandela effect thing people
gonna think like Will Smith was never a
GD in a movie that was Sinbad feels like
the same thing a little bit yeah people
like some of those but not all of it
copying it Hellboy released a trailer
and Avengers end game released a new
IMAX version of their trailer too so
it's trailer city I cleared a few things
up though the end game trailer that is
such as nebulae nebula definitely being
with Tony most likely on the benitar oh
there was some confusion right what do
you guys think of the Hellboy trailer
there mm-hmm that's Hellboy face a lid
longer leave it if she needs a little
wider if you guys really really wanted
him to be violent like you got that like
it kind of took I don't know if it has
the same like magic in that for in the
Guillermo movies yeah those were great I
really wish there was a third one yeah
Adam guy mentioned in an interview that
Marvel may be in the early stages of a
Nova or just speculated everybody I mean
the one Marvel movie he worked on he
left it wasn't under good terms or that
Adam McKay doesn't know no he came and
finished that one
he finished yeah he finished that he
stepped in with Paul Rudd just improvise
their way through this one I'm so bad
and you guys didn't even know rewind it
did it twice and then we went back to us
haha
instead you didn't realize this I can
tell me that now so I'm just gonna let
it go really bad at talking and
listening at the same time I'm really
bad it's a New Year's resolution I'm
working on listening active listening
did you just say something else while I
had to share my new year's the worst
okay guys our New York sirs news
lightning round oh oh you guys tweeted
us some questions I got them here I'm
gonna fire them at all of us we got to
answer as quickly and without hesitation
as possible are we ready yeah Sam first
ones coming at you at troppo soar a
Tropos Dan wants to know should DCE you
reboot a little bit crowded let's just
let's not reboot let's just take a cut
let's go five let's do a fly free group
and then we'll just keep going and we'll
keep moving ahead yeah there's some good
there's some bad let's take the good
make it better
yep mod at charissa main wants to know
which MCU movie is the most Christmassy
which really yeah I guess there's one
that set a Christmas oh that's right and
really what they did and they did they
blow up the Chinese Theatre okay for me
Venkman one two two one wants to know
what was your go-to breakfast cereal as
a kid whenever I had the most sugar
right oh the rice krispies treats cereal
that was something that was already made
out of rice krispies turn into another
snack and it turned back into a cereal I
think I had rice krispies and I would
break up chunks and put that over every
morning crying yeah it's great sugar
squares Sam and crimson vegan what's to
know
good star-lord had been snapped out of a
physical body and then become eternity
and come back and destroy tennis because
of Gamora if you want to do all the
legwork of literally fixing the universe
but this - I'm gonna say I was gonna say
hard pass on that one
it's anything could bond theory though
but a horde does love it sweetie good
baby
I mean maybe it's like cuz there's that
moment at guardians to where you looked
at me like I see Dad okay for me sensei
I am one what's no Nadia sting you did
this well in front of my body and say I
wore something that exposed too much of
myself and we'll just say that that's
probably the naughtiest thing that I'm
willing to share is quite omadd's got it
ideal anti-human jazz if you could be
the spy the spider grin or Lady Deadpool
for the rest of your life who would you
choose I mean I'm gonna watch
spider-verse because there's fight a
grandmaster spider grand but Lady
Deadpool gets to say some bad words yeah
but then you have you have the face the
Deadpool face thank you I am vain this
last question is my favorite type of and
we get an MCU x-men fan casts for the
fan cast okay okay Mars and he's coming
back that's cos already
kelsey grammer he's still kicking around
with Nightcrawler
Nightcrawler you're gonna do Alan
because he was great nothing
wrong we could probably go better uh-huh
no I mean that they already nailed it
okay I went miles tell her to play every
character in it what are you doing I'm
Kitty Pryde now I'm Kitty Pryde
[Music]
professor Enix there's nothing wrong
with who do you want to recast who's
Heisenberg who's that man who is that
man who plays Heisenberg see my Cranston
hey my god a magneto Bryan Cranston for
professor xox doing like a Dick Van Dyke
cockney accent the whole time yes the
whole time move on great great questions
and now comes the time for a 15-second
shout out where each of us gets 15
seconds to shout out plug or ramble
begging I got one this is my Christmas
time share that I love to I want
everyone in the world to see this and
every year I check back and there's only
like 150 thousand views on this video
and it's the best Christmas video we'll
put you in the Christmas spirit in the
90s there was a National Mall Christmas
concert where Patti LaBelle was brought
on stage to sing this Christmas with the
Marine Corps band well she didn't know
the words to her own song so she had to
have some staffer hold up cue cards and
the band starts right away everything
about this is botched there was no
rehearsal she gets announced and she
comes out too early for the very
beginning she supposed that background
singers the background singers are
nowhere in sight there were bleachers
empty bleachers behind her
she's wearing a choir robe for no reason
and it's uh she's singing the words but
she's another word so she'll go this
Christmas because I don't know the words
to my own
the one guy's job to change the cards
doesn't just to give a shout-out to the
trombonist at some point crumble it's
the it's a Christmas miracle and I want
you all to watch and enjoy it I'll tweet
it out oh do you have yours I remember I
put my myself because I've got nothing
else to think about my patreon is gonna
go over some really big changes in 2019
so that's probably the best time ever to
join up out of geek Baum's patreon
including I don't know check it out
there'll be a bunch of stuff happening
some cool things I'm doing a bunch of
photo shoots as well which I'm really
excited by by the way this is what
anyway and geek bomb still has that it's
my favorite thing to say about geek bomb
so I got a hundred thousand I got my
silver Bachmann and then I think I maxed
out at like 108 subscribers and you
should just do a purge to get a bunch of
likes so bad it was about three or four
months so it's actually been consecutive
over the last eight months weird just
like they do a mess I'm following of a
lot of my subscribers like even people
who write and contribute for geek balm
who've been subscribed for like six
years have been unsubscribe crazy guys
so that's fun y'all or move YouTube
thanks for that one for me I'm gonna
just give a shout out to the best
Instagram out there let me get the name
right let me get the name right it's
more to Garrett with us there you go
Jerry of the day it's I've been watching
it all night it's been giving me a lot
of joy its ski fails and I've been
finding out about this weird subculture
of bro easkey dudes and it's so weird
ifs I think it's kind of learning
Canadian slang and it's been such a
wandering Jerry is just a bonehead man a
straight-up course he's straight up like
he's trying to do a trick he can't do it
but he's gonna whip it and then you just
gotta send it you just gotta send it
I bought a bunch of merch from it after
they have with a cup holder on it and
I'm gonna wear it in and it's amazing
it's so good you guys
Jerry check out all these things and
let's move on to our trivia answer to
the question we asked earlier and bring
back a gif of shame yeah
thank you again Travis we're so excited
to bring this into our world so as
always the loser will have to draw a
question from the gift for Shane stay in
front of the green screen do a bunch of
weird motions and we want you guys to
turn that into something crazy and fun
on Twitter but it's remind us of what
the question was it was named another
project that Jason Momoa had to be an
excellent swimmer so let's see what man
I didn't get it Oh nannies were really
good to him melee you guys gotta follow
him more entertainment sites where they
do before and after pictures from his
time on this show I get sucked into
those ads at the bottom of IGN we like
you wouldn't believe who was in this
Eric said Batman V Superman dawn of
Justice yeah I mean he had to swim in it
fans said frontier the Netflix hit and
Maude said Baywatch which which the
correct answer like BAE was like david
hasselhoff baywatch Wow later series he
came in I think a little bit later how
how old is he Wow well I think he was
like 17 or 19 when you joined Baywatch
way to go my dear yeah I mean I think
it's a cop-out to say Batman V Superman
were talking about Aquaman's frontier
it's a honestly it's a frontier show
he's a starving kind of Lake yep
near a lake I've ever watched this show
I don't think anyone is swims in BBS he
does that weird he I mean is it swimming
if he's living down there oh that was
real stupid
that was a really dumb of me to say
oh good nothing like teamwork to another
a nor new box well okay so mods gonna do
our goodbyes while Sam and I joined the
gift of shame Club did he write this one
Sam one of them says boys only
[Music]
yeah good luck with that what is there
is only one so yeah see if we can find
boys only to I right good luck guys
what's that a poll appears single
dollars rain down on you you minx boys
only boys only
okay so mods gonna read our goodbyes are
you doing your radios by the way oh
we're both doing different ones Oh both
do that one I break through that one Oh
girls dreams do come true this is gonna
be so good
oh what's that there's a pole same good
um somehow your nipple tassels going
nipple tassels Sam yeah thank you guys
so much for watching new rock stars and
joining me in this endeavor this is so
good make sure you've got moves I've
never seen alrighty like the video share
it around make well they're only dollar
bills buddy and make sure you turn that
gif into something pretty sweet and
share it all over the internet forever
and destroy their careers subscribe to
new rock stars as well for the deep
dives on stuff you love this is at Sam
Basha aka diamond tits
[Laughter]
and Eric you can catch me at EA vas and
he is also known as candy floss ah I'm
more dirty couldn't get me dead on the
pole to touch next time bye guys bye
entirely true Christmas parties
Christmas parties is something like that
could happen you never know